thomas
[Musique]
il ya une limite sur un tee shirt
je n'ai pas dépassé car je ressentais on
est passé quelques jours à peine après
que les appeler sadok c'est quoi ta un
iphone voire en dessous
[Rires]
[Musique]
le make up facebook mark zuckerberg des
meilleures ventes on va tous les miens
avis l'échangé
justin à mon humble c'est pas mal non
plus steve jobs compte a dit steve jobs
ses fils
[Rires]
premièrement ça j'aurais dû le faire des
vidéos jusqu'à las mais je ne crois pas
aux classes bonne ambiance qui lui dit
libre et là dit elle répondait au nom de
bell
[Rires]
en tout cas on est
ah ah
[Musique]
et j'aimerais qu'on fasse le jeu n'aura
pas de solution
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aussi vous les promesses d'aujourd'hui
l'enfant villa est sur la même coupe la
lazio la roma
[Musique]
m
jeannot prix robert t qu'est ce que dit
on hisse au caire était parsemé souffre
lui de bras
cette fuite l'arceau est plus grave
[Applaudissements]
allo
john holmes
[Musique]